quoi il a induit les canadiens en erreur
depuis le début de la semaine les
questions fusent sur la mission en irak
les questions persistantes depuis que
l'on a appris que ce n'est pas une fois
mais à trois reprises que les canadiens
ont affronté directement les forces du
groupe armé état islamique
depuis que l'on a appris aussi qu'ils
sont les seuls de la coalition avoir
pris part à de tels combats
la pression le ton du premier ministre
franchi un cap
je sais que l'opposition trouve terrible
qu'on se tienne debout face aux
djihadistes affirment qu'ils veulent un
peu sans me dire que certains d'entre
eux se soient fait tuer par du notaire
canadien en tout cas le bureau du
premier ministre
embrasse la rhétorique
une nouvelle vidéo sur son site web
trois minutes de discours patriotique
sur l'addition en irak sur la menace
terroriste
nous ne serons pas intimider
le canada ne sera jamais seule on
n'hésite pas à invoquer l'attentât au
parlement la mort du caporal celio ses
funérailles
alors qu'au bureau du premier ministre
on affirme qu'il s'agit avant tout
d'appuyer une forces canadiennes ça
c'est une honte
comme sur l'opposition c'est le début
d'un dérapage avec l'argent des
contribuables
ce que le prévenu ne s'est en train
d'essayer de faire c'est de changer de
chaîne pour qu'on regarde pas le vrai
par les missiles parce que le vrai
problème tout le monde le reconnaît
c'est que stephen harper a menti aux
canadiens dans ce climat préélectoral la
guerre la menace terroriste semble donc
devenu un enjeu partisan pour mousser le
leadership de stephen harper mais les
questions sur la mission en irak demeure
et les ministres des affaires étrangères
et de la défense nationale n'y
échapperont pas lors de leur témoignage
en comité parlementaire
judy et ses manuels à travers ce radio
canada ottawa